the cloud threat landscape report and
the introduction of IBM intelligent
remediation all on this episode of IBM
Tech now what's up y'all my name is Ian
and I am back to bring you the latest
and greatest news and announcements
about IBM technology
cyber security is a business imperative
failing to manage threats can result in
costly data leaks lost customer loyalty
and even legal action
to build a more agile defense against
the constantly evolving landscape of
cyber threats you'll need the most
up-to-date information available that's
why we're excited for the release of the
IBM X-Force Cloud threat landscape
report which analyzes real-world cyber
security incidents over the preceding 12
months to provide practical defense
strategies and invaluable insights
let's look at a few of the key findings
first misuse of legitimate credentials
is the most used security exploit in
fact incident response data shows that
36 percent of incidents involve the
misuse of valid credentials
should come as no surprise then that the
report found that the dark web is
teeming with stolen Cloud credentials
stolen credentials accounted for nearly
95 percent of cloud assets available on
the dark web at an average sale price of
only 10.68
the report also found that
discoverability and disclosure of
vulnerabilities are on the rise IBM
X-Force tracks 632 unique cloud-related
common vulnerabilities and exposures or
cves in the 12 months before the report
that's a 194 increase from the prior
year in other words Cloud CVS have
nearly tripled year over year
these are just a few of the main
findings of the cloud threat landscape
report to read the report and get the
full rundown check out the link in the
description of this video
next up it incidents are bad for
business and can result in poor customer
experiences and cost organizations
millions of dollars in fact an IDC
survey found that the most common
estimate for an hour of downtime for a
revenue generating service was between a
hundred thousand and two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
in today's fast-paced digital
environment traditional ticket-based
incident response processes may not be
fast enough to meet the businesses
demands businesses need a new approach
one that can help accelerate response
times and leverage Automation in AI for
incident remediation
that's why we're thrilled to introduce a
new way to help accelerate incident
remediation with IBM intelligent
remediation
this new capability is planned for use
with both IBM and Stana and IBM AI Ops
insights it also leverages IBM Watson X
solutions to guide and automate incident
remediation by providing operations
teams with recommended actions to
diagnose and remediate the incident it
even provides the ability to execute
those actions using automation tools
like red hat ansible
IBM intelligent remediation is designed
to provide out-of-the-box automation
tools and it leverages Watson xcode
assistant for assisted tailoring and
creation of additional remediation and
diagnostic data collection actions
simply put IBM intelligent remediation
presents options and gives you
automation tools to implement the
recommended actions this enables
operations to rapidly address incidents
and accelerate response times
to learn more hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now